Joe: [British accent] From
calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Dunkin' Donuts –
haha, it's me!
OK, I'll do it for real.
From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Dunkin' Donuts
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
At Dunkin' Donuts in the US,
you can get your doughnuts
in three different...
sizes, I guess?
One doughnut,
half a dozen doughnuts, nice,
and, of course, everyone's favorite,
dozen doughnuts.
Harry: In the UK, our doughnuts also come
in three quantities,
and, shockingly, it's the
same as in the States.
You can get one doughnut,
a half dozen doughnuts,
or you can be the life of the party
with the full dozen.
Joe: And it's "Food Wars," so you know
we're weighing a doughnut.
Harry: Now let's see how
much a glazed doughnut
weighs in the UK.
Our glazed doughnut came to
pretty much exactly 50 grams,
so it looks like the States
are getting a better deal.
Joe: At a US Dunkin' Donuts,
you can get your Munchkins
in four different units of Munchkin.
Five Munchkins.
10 Munchkins.
Not enough?
Kick it up to 25 Munchkins.
See that?
And if that isn't enough,
you can go all the way to 50 Munchkins.
50 of these things!
Wow, look at the size of this!
It's a lot of Munchkins.
Harry: In the UK, we also
have four units of Munchkin,
starting with four.
From there, we move upwards to...
12 Munchkins.
The next size up from 12
is in a box,
and the box contains...
24 Munchkins.
And, finally,
our biggest size of Munchkins in the UK
is 50.
Now, it might not make too much sense
to compare just one Munchkin
in the UK and the US,
because I'm sure they're all
slightly different shapes and sizes.
However, what we could do is
measure 24 Munchkins here
and 24 Munchkins there
and hope that it provides
a kind of overview
of the average weight.
That sound about right?
Joe: Sounds like science to me.
Let's do it.
All right.
This is 25, so I'm going to take one out.
Harry: Can I do it without spilling?
Oh, God.
Joe: Whoop.
Harry: [laughing] Oh, God.
Looking like a croquembouche.
What, how is that so good?
OK. Munchkin challenge No. 1:
How many Munchkins can I fit in my mouth
at one time without dying?
[jazzy music]
Cameraman: I'm not ready.
Joe: Can you hurry this up, man?
We got other stuff to --
ahhh!
[laughs]
If you guessed seven,
you were roughly right.
Although I felt like I sort of cheated,
because I almost died.
Joe: In the US Dunkin' Donuts,
our hot coffees come in four sizes.
Small.
Harry: In the UK,
our hot coffees come in two sizes,
regular and large.
Joe: Large
and
extra large.
The Dunkin' Donuts US website
says that their large
hot coffee is 20 ounces.
Got a measuring cup here,
let's find out if that is true.
Now, full disclosure,
on the car ride over here,
had a little bit of a spillage.
So I'm gonna give this one,
we'll say, a 2-ounce leeway.
Should be 20 ounces, might be 18.
Yo!
OK, that's 16.
4 more ounces.
[blows a raspberry]
Give me a break!
That's maybe an ounce.
16 plus one, I think, is still 17.
There is no way
there is
this much of coffee
on my car seat.
Let's generously add 2 –
16, 17, 18, 19 –
I don't want to be that generous.
Wait a second.
I got an idea.
20 ounces, so that means
I need 4 in here, correct?
OK. That's 20 ounces.
I'm gonna settle this right now.
OK. There's 16 in a cup, plus 4.
You know what's about to happen.
You ready?
[suspenseful music]
Come on, now.
Harry: Now, that all seems very dramatic,
so I'm also gonna
measure our large coffee.
Not a black coffee.
Did I get that with milk?
I'm so stupid.
I just remembered I put milk in the large.
So, we're going to measure anyway
and see what happens.
Looks pretty much exactly 16 ounces.
Iced coffees in the UK
also come in two sizes, regular and large.
Joe: At a Dunkin' Donuts in the US,
we have three iced-coffee sizes,
small,
mediums,
and the large.
Harry: [laughing] No one needs, like,
32 ounces of coffee.
That's just too much.
Joe: 32 ounces.
Do I have enough for 32 ounces?
This is 16, and this is...
8. No, I don't.
Harry: We're also gonna
measure our large iced coffee
to see what it comes to.
So, a large iced coffee in
the UK came to 18 ounces.
Joe: Since I don't have
another 16-ounce cup,
I will use this one.
Right on the 16.
OK. That's one 16 ounce.
Oh, jeez.
This is exactly 16 ounces here.
Was this the large?
Conner: I think that was the large, yeah.
Joe: This should be 16 more fluid ounces.
Shameful.
Absolutely shameful.
There definitely was not
this much space left in the cup.
27 1/2 fluid ounces
in your 32-ounce large iced coffee.
It's still almost to the, I mean –
our PA just pointed out
that maybe the density is different,
right when you put exactly
the most frozen ice?
Maybe.
Well, let's ask someone who's a scientist.
[laughs]
Harry: Not a scientist, but
that won't change anything,
and you guys are still kind
of getting a bit shortchanged.
It's just 'cause the density
of the solid or the liquid might change.
The actual amount of liquid in there
is still going to be the same,
so it should all balance
itself out eventually.
Joe: At the US Dunkin' Donuts,
the largest single food item you can get
is this, two dozen doughnuts,
and the largest drink you can get is
a Box O' Joe.
Look at this.
Think that's about 100
fluid ounces of coffee.
I've always wanted to do this.
It's, like, really hot in here.
OK.
Ahh!
Just set this down on my seat and be like,
"This is my coffee.
All right?"
Then write my name right
on it, right there.
"Joe, do not touch."
Conner: It's already on it.
Joe: What? Is it?
Oh, yeah. [laughs]
Mine, baby!
Mine!
Oh, man, I've already
drank way too much coffee.
[laughs]
Harry: Now, the biggest
thing on the menu in the UK
is the Dunkin' Feast.
This is two dozen doughnuts, 50 Munchkins,
and two Boxes O' Joe,
all for a price of 80 pounds.
Now, unfortunately, when we went in today,
they didn't have any
Boxes O' Joe available.
However, one of them is supposed to be
100 fluid ounces of coffee,
which is far too much coffee.
Joe: [laughs]
This here is a US glazed
Dunkin' Donut doughnut.
It is roughly 360 calories,
has 22 grams of fat,
10 of those are saturated,
420 milligrams of sodium, 39 carbs,
and 18 grams of sugar.
Harry: And in the UK, the same
doughnut has 230 calories,
13 grams of fat, 230 milligrams of sodium,
25 grams of carbs, and 10 grams of sugar.
Joe: So, by my calculations,
the US glazed doughnut
is 56.5% higher in calories,
69.2% higher in fat,
and 80% higher in sugar.
I gotta burp. [burps]
Sorry.
Let's talk about another doughnut,
the Boston Kreme doughnut.
I don't know why it's shaped like a heart.
I'm assuming 'cause it's Valentine's.
We're shooting this in February.
Normally, it's a circle.
Anyway, this doughnut has
270 calories,
11 grams of fat, 18 grams of sugar.
Harry: The UK version of the Boston Kreme
contains 280 calories,
15 grams of fat, 17 grams of sugar.
So that has more calories and fat.
Joe: A large iced coffee
with cream and sugar,
in the US, has roughly 260 cu –
[blows a raspberry]
Hang on.
Conner: Yeah.
Joe: [claps] Back to life, baby!
A large iced coffee at a
Dunkin' Donuts in the US
has 260 calories,
18 grams of fat,
and 37 grams of carbs.
That seems like a lot, doesn't it?
Harry: In the UK, a large Dunkin' coffee
with cream and sugar
comes to 190 calories,
with 9.1 grams of fat
and 30.4 grams of carbs.
Joe: If we break it down by fluid ounce,
it turns out the US is higher
in every metric except carbs.
Just look at all that data.
Thinking about adding a
flavor pump to your coffee?
In the US and the UK,
you can get vanilla,
caramel, hazelnut flavors.
On average in the US, though,
when you add those pumps,
you are adding 165 calories,
38 grams of carbs,
and 37 more grams of sugar.
All of our information from the UK
for this episode was taken from
not Dunkin' Donuts UK,
but other nutrition sites
and food bloggers and whatever.
Assuming that the iced coffee
in the US and [UK] Dunkin'
Donuts are the same,
not sure if it is, they didn't tell us,
thanks a lot, Dunkin' Donuts UK,
but assuming it is the same,
to get this large iced
coffee with cream and sugar
and these two doughnuts
we talked about earlier,
total, it is 890 calories,
which is 35.6% of your daily intake.
Harry: And in the UK,
a large iced coffee with cream and sugar,
a glazed doughnut, and
a Boston Kreme doughnut
comes to 700 calories,
or 28% of your daily allowance.
Joe: What about Munchkins?
In the US, one glazed
Munchkin is 60 calories,
3 grams of fat, 60 milligrams of sodium,
7 grams of carbs, and 3 grams of sugar.
Harry: Now, unfortunately,
Dunkin' in the UK
does not release any of its
ingredients information.
We did reach out to see if
they'd make an exception,
but unfortunately, at the
time we're shooting this,
they had not.
Joe: US Dunkin' Donuts' website does have
a majority of its
nutritional info on the site.
Let me read you some hits right now.
OK, first, the coffee. Hot or cold,
it's 100% brewed arabica coffee.
Fantastic.
Now, if you want to add
cream and sugar to your coffee
like a 16-year-old influencer,
now you've added milk, cream,
disodium phosphate as a stabilizer,
sodium citrate as a stabilizer,
and sugar.
Of the many flavor shots
you can add to the coffee in the US,
I picked the caramel one,
'cause it's also available in the UK,
assuming that it is the same
in the US and the UK.
In the US, the caramel
shots are made up of
sweetened condensed nonfat milk,
which is nonfat milk and sugar,
high-fructose corn syrup,
and sugar, water, and brown sugar,
so three different
various sugar substances.
Fantastic.
Caramel color,
potassium sorbate as a preservative,
natural flavors, and salt.
A glazed doughnut at a US Dunkin' Donuts
is made up of enriched wheat flour,
which is flour, malted barley –
[laughs]
Holy s---. OK.
Niacin, reduced iron,
thiamine mononitrate,
riboflavin, folic acid,
all right,
water, palm oil,
yeast doughnut concentrate,
brackets, which is soy flour, salt,
leavening,
sodium acid pyrophosphate,
baking soda,
[sighs]
wheat starch, whey (a milk derivative),
nonfat dry milk,
gum blend,
which is cellulous gum,
guar gum, acacia gum,
carrageenan, and xanthan gum.
A lot of gum.
Can you scroll up, please?
[clears throat]
Sodium caseinate, which
is a milk derivative,
sodium stearloyl lassithate,
lass-,
lactylate,
and it contains 2% or less of
soybean oil, soy lecithin,
whole egg, natural flavors,
turmeric extract for color, enzymes,
annatto extract for
color, yeast, dextrose,
soybean oil, and mono and diglycerides.
OK, that's the dough.
Now for the glaze!
We ain't even done yet.
Scroll up, please.
The glaze of a glazed doughnut has
sugar, water, maltodextrin,
and contains 2% or less of cornstarch,
mono and diglycerides, citric acid, agar,
cellulose gum, potassium
sorbate as a preservative,
and, of course, artificial flavors.
That's a lot of stuff.
So, what's in the Boston
Kreme doughnut, you ask?
All right, the dough is the
same as the glazed dough,
but the Bavarian cream filling is
water, sugar, modified food starch,
corn syrup, palm oil,
and it contains 2% or less of
sucrose esters,
natural and artificial flavors,
oh, my God,
glucono
delta
lact-
I mean, they're just making
fun of me at this point.
Glucono
delta
- lactone.
Sounds like a font.
Salt, potassium sorbate
and sodium benzonate for preservatives,
and agar, and beta-carotene for color.
And, of course, don't forget
about the chocolate icing,
which is sugar, water,
cocoa, high-fructose corn syrup,
soybean oil, cornstarch,
corn syrup, maltodextrin,
and contains 2% or less of dextrose,
palm oil, salt,
potassium sorbate and sodium propionate
(preservatives), soy lecithin,
artificial flavors, and agar.
And you know what?
I'm not going through every doughnut.
Here's everything exclusive
to the US at Dunkin' Donuts.
Harry: Here is everything
you will only find
on the menu at a UK Dunkin' Donuts.
Joe: I'm not sure if they have any bagels
at the UK Dunkin' Donuts,
but in the US, you can
get cinnamon raisin,
you can get sesame, everything,
oh, and you can also get, of course,
English muffins.
An English muffin?
How come England doesn't
have the English muffins?
Makes you wonder. Makes you wonder.
Harry: Here are the exclusive doughnuts
you can only find in the UK.
There are a lot of them,
and I've forgotten all of their names,
so I'm just gonna make up
names for them as I go,
and then we can put the actual
names up on screen for you.
Let's start with this one.
This is Sonic the Hedgehog.
It's very, very bright.
If you see something that's
this color in nature,
just do not eat it.
This one, I believe, is
Mr. Happy, a smiley face.
It's kind of cute, or sinister, perhaps,
depending on your
interpretation of things.
[creepy music]
It's worth noting that
some of these are only here
because we're filming this
in the run-up to Valentine's Day,
so they've got a bit of a
love theme going on right now.
This one is
Love Dust,
Flatline,
Pretty in Pink,
Heart Bypass,
Love Prison,
'cause it's like jail-cell bars.
This one is, um, Keith.
This one I'm jazzed about.
This is the apple crumble doughnut.
Now, I know American pie
is a very American thing,
whereas in the UK, we
quite like a crumble.
Instead of pastry, we
have a kind of, like,
flour and butter crumble mix on top.
Joe: So many different doughnuts
in the US, not in the UK.
I didn't want to do every single
doughnut that's different,
but three that I feel are, like,
kinda like the hits that I
would figure were everywhere,
they're apparently not in the UK,
are an old-fashioned.
This one, right?
Apple fritter.
Hang on.
It's so good.
And the coffee roll.
Look at the size of this coffee roll, man!
It's like a spare tire.
Hell, yeah.
A coffee cake muffin.
Also, in the US, you can get corn muffins
at some Dunkin' Donuts.
Not the one that I went to, unfortunately.
Breakfast sandwiches.
Dunkin' Donuts in the US
has so many different
varieties of sandwiches,
far too many to mention in this.
I got as many as I could find.
So, one of these is a turkey,
sausage, egg, and cheese.
The other one is
a Beyond meat breakfast sandwich.
These all look the same.
Veggie, egg-white omelet sandwich
on the protein thins.
The Power Breakfast sandwich.
I don't know –
this one.
What is this?
This one's got, like, some
bacon and stuff on it.
An egg white with bacon
sandwich on a croissant?
Here's just a few other
ones that are available
in the US and not in the UK
that I couldn't get my
hands on. Limited menu.
The Belgian waffle breakfast sandwich,
maple sugar bacon,
Big N' Toasty,
Angus steak sandwich.
They also have chicken bacon sandwiches,
a chicken biscuit,
which I would love to have had.
Wasn't available.
And, of course, their
exclusive grilled cheese.
Also, they have Snackin'
Bacon and those Dunkin' bowls.
I can't believe that didn't have those.
Like, I got those just recently.
Along with bagels,
you can also get white
cheddar bagel twists.
Harry: And, finally, we
have a few other items
that you will only find in the UK.
We'll start with these two cookies.
This one is a chocolate chunk cookie,
and this one is a salted caramel cookie.
This one looks, like, aggressively salty.
There's big chunks of sand.
Not sand. Salt.
[laughter]
Sand would be a gross cookie!
Then we have two exclusive
hot coffee options,
which are the cortado and the flat white.
A cortado is a foamed milk
and espresso combination,
and a flat white is a steamed
milk and espresso combination.
Then we have a couple of
exclusive cold options, as well.
This one is a mango Coolatta,
which is like a mango-flavored
kind of blended-ice drink.
It looks pretty good.
I can imagine that being quite
refreshing on a summer's day.
And then, finally, we have this,
which is a shaken lemonade.
It kind of just looks like water now.
I'm not sure if that's just
because it's been sat here
for a while under the lights,
but it was quite impressive
to watch the lady make it in the shop.
She was actually going at
it with a cocktail shaker,
and it was a bit of fun.
Joe: The drinks!
So many different drinks
that you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
I'll just start down here.
First one, iced cappuccino.
Am I taking a sip of everything?
Iced cappuccino.
Yeah, it's all right.
Frozen chocolate,
iced Americano,
peach passion fruit Refresher,
a strawberry dragon fruit Refresher.
The only hot one we have
here is a matcha latte.
Iced matcha latte.
Ooh! We're talking about the Coolattas!
Yo!
♪ Coolattas, yeah! ♪
Strawberry Coolatta.
Ooh.
A little tart.
I like that.
[straw squeaks]
Conserving straws.
Yeah, that's, ooh, that's the best one.
Blue raspberry.
Blues, blue wa, raspberry Coo, Coolatta.
I know I when I was on my high horse
about how sweet these beverages are
and how bad it is for you?
Coolattas, pretty nice.
A green Coolatta.
That's something matcha.
I don't know what that is.
There's matcha in it.
And last but not least,
at least I don't think.
OK.
This is a
milk-colored Coolatta.
Ahh.
I can't imagine this being any good.
Whoa, that's actually pretty good.
Yeah, it's vanilla.
This is too much of any of these,
but I would have a Coolatta
if it came in, like, 3 ounces,
just like a shot.
Harry: Whoever's still
stuck around to watch this,
I'm gonna try and fit a
whole doughnut in my mouth.
Let's go.
[garbled] Subscribe to
Food Insider for more.
Nailed it. Nailed it.